[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club
it was round six of the Fall Classic
here in st. Louis Group a has been blown
open
Aleksey drea was unable to increase his
lead by much and he has five players
chasing close by in be branded
Jacobson's pawn push cost him the game
against Conrad Hulk there is now a
slight chance that kaboom can clinch the
field in seven Big Show downs today
round seven starts now twenty
international chess professionals
compete in st. Louis as US chess champs
calm presents the second annual fall
chess classic the Central West End is
bustling today as our longtime partner
the coffee cartel has its final day of
operation the line is out the door as
patrons line up for their last cups of
Joe we think owner Dennis George and his
staff for 22 years as an anchor in our
neighborhood but time marches on and
just down the street on Maryland Avenue
at a little place called the st. Louis
chess club the fall chess classic is
underway welcome to round seven
hello chess fans Ben Simon here with
international master Eric Rosen and we
have some big games in store today we do
and while I'm very sad about the coffee
cartel I am happy to be here and looking
at some hopefully very exciting chests
no doubt about it let's start it off not
wait it's not wasting a lot of time
let's take a look at the group a
standings after six rounds have been
completed and you can see Alexi Dre up
there still at the top leading by only
half a point he has five chasers
Lenderman Kusi bamako bian hansen and
brews own and in the next two days
anything could happen
now we do have a result already and
we'll get to that in a moment so that
does affect it just a little bit but
still any
a chess tournament here in Group A and
now the standings for Group B after six
rounds have been completed it's a little
bit of a different story as - Eska boos
Ian if the stars aligned could clinch
this group today with two rounds
remaining so we will be keeping an eye
on his game as he's playing Brandon
Jacobson
okay so let's glance at our tournament
format if you're joining us for the very
first time this is 210 player round
robins the time control is game in 90
minutes for the first 40 moves and there
is a 30 minute addition for the
remainder of the game
there's a 30 second increment from move
number one and the players cannot agree
to a draw before blacks thirtieth move
30 30 30 that's a lot of 30s 130 yeah
and now our tournament schedule we have
two days remaining after this one
tomorrow is a regular day Wednesday
October 17th the games start at 1:00
p.m. just as they did today we're we are
on the air with you at 3:30 p.m. Central
Time now on Thursday the finale
to make room for playoffs we are going
to be starting early this broadcast will
begin at 1:30 p.m. Central Time and we
encourage you to check out the game
starting at 11:00 at us chest champs
calm and all along the way be sure not
only to watch us on the website but
we're on YouTube we are on Twitch the
chess 24 module is rockin and we have
our own hashtag on Twitter hashtag fall
chess classic join the conversation I
have YouTube open right now and if you
guys have any thoughtful questions you
would like to shoot our way do just that
and we will do our best to answer them
okay let's get to our pairings in group
a for round 7 varoujan Akopian vs. Eric
Hanson Cuza ba vs. spirits cerumen vs.
brews owned Robson vs. hammer and our
key matchup Eric Wright grandmaster
Alexander Linderman taking on Alexei
dray of
this game is already over one of the
quickest decisive games in the
tournament I do want to take a look at
how the game has ended hopefully we'll
have maybe one or two of these players
in the studio of it later but dre of
playing the Carroll Khan with black
winning in just 23 moves this is a final
position I'm not going to go through the
whole game because we probably will have
someone in the studio to take us through
it but just looking at the final
position 97 very nice kind of backward
but venomous move with the simple threat
of 96 and Lenderman has to regret has to
be regretting here is his earlier play
given that box pawns are just so
menacing on f3 and g4 and there's really
no escape for the white queen on h4
given that it's just completely
dominated by blacks pieces all the
squares around it are controlled 96 is
simply unstoppable
so very nice waiting for draya's he is
um
he's undefeated and tournament only
player in Group A who is undefeated and
it's looking more and more likely that
he's gonna win in this this section two
more days to go and that's two more days
for anybody to find an answer to the Dre
of riddle okay and now let's look at
Group B round seven here are the
pairings for that section we have Ashwin
Jha ROM versus Sergey Azeroth L Shawn
more dia body versus Stephens ERK Danish
Boros versus Chris you conrad Holt
versus Akshat Chandra and our key
matchup Erik Havana's go Busey and
playing Brandon Jacobson who is the
mystery man I guess he missed a photo
shoot that's possible this is another
game very critical to the standings
which has actually just ended gooo Busey
and taking down the youngster I do want
to glance at this final position as well
go Busey and has won in 30 moves final
move being Knight takes c6 I was looking
at this game about 50
20 minutes ago go booze ian had over an
hour on the clock and Brandon Jacobson
had under a minute so it goes to show
time management is important if we take
a look at this position this is a simple
fork the king and the rook are attacked
white snip next move is undoubtedly
Knight 88 and light will just be up
enough material to put put black away in
this position so hopefully we can get
the the winners in the studio Dre of and
good booze Ian because they're looking
more and more likely to be the winners
of Group A and Group B respectively
yeah and man the first two games and
there are key matchups that hasn't
happened before so very interesting
stuff so far I do understand we will
have a Lexie Drive in the studio and he
will be accompanied by his opponent
actually Alexander London to handle any
translation issues that come about so
that's very nice we will be able to talk
to him so let's look at some other games
in the meantime before I give you some
suggestions have you do you have
anything that caught your eye there's a
game that immediately catches my eye the
battle between Denish Boros and
Christopher you
I interviewed Christopher a couple days
ago in the studio and he was saying that
he's just looking to play good chess
take one game at a time and not
necessarily play too
solidly or two too aggressively just
react to how the game goes and it seems
like this this game is unraveling in a
very very sharp fashion current position
here a lot of tension in the position I
want to go back just a few moves and see
how we got to such a crazy situation
this is a one of the sharper variations
of the north and this is an opening that
I don't like to play myself simply
because it's just simply too too
headache-inducing
given that there's there's so many
complications that can arise with white
having Castle queenside and black having
Castle kingside clearly both players
want to attack each other's King in the
middle game going forward here white
played a three to perhaps slow down
this before push and then after a bishop
t7 white expanded on the King side with
h4 Queen b6 was played tricia pig f6
Bishop take f6 white continues upon
storm here with pawn g5 Bishop e7 and
then pawn h5 so it just seems to be
raining pawns on the Kings side and
usually in cases like this when you're
when you're pushing pawns the main goal
is to open up files so the rooks can
ultimately come into play we can very
soon imagine that white would like to
play rook g1 and then can very easily
predict one if not both of these moves
between h6 and g6 will come so going
forward a5 is played black on the in the
meantime is Colin storming on the Queen
side after g6 before attacking the
knight on c3 Denish ignored this and
simply played h6 here or maybe not so
simply given that okay the the position
is simply about to explode given that
first of all Locke could take the knight
on c3 but it seems like there's enormous
threats on the King side given that
White's either wants to take on g7 or
take on h7 can imagine here if B takes
c3 I would think white can take on h7
first and the black king is perhaps
running low on shelter if the King were
to recapture name 7h take g7 is pretty
much all she wrote given that I don't
think the black king will be surviving
this attack now that the the G file and
the H file have opened up a simple move
like Queen g2 and we can have some fun
with a now analyzing the final checkmate
in this position perhaps King to f6 rook
to h6 King is dragged up into the center
of the board and okay simple made in one
queen g3 would end the game so I'm sure
Christopher is searching for ways to
avoid his king being dropped up the
board like this but it was a question
how to deal with these
on g6 and h6 it's a it's a bit funny
just to see the paw intention here black
has so many different captures to
consider but I do like the creativity by
Denish in this position given that he's
just ignoring the the queenside play for
the time being and just going all out on
the kingside Wow yeah the world number 2
under 12 years old Chris you looks like
he is in real trouble right here this is
heavy stuff here on that King side she
does have a time to think which is which
is very important in this type of
situation I would probably imagine him
to capture on g6 perhaps F take g6 seems
like an attempt to try and be safe
problem with this move is that it
somewhat strengthens the bishop now that
II 6 is more of a targets and white
could take on g7 allowing the Queen 10
tour the attack I would just be
terrified here if I were in
Christopher's position alright well
we've glanced at this game a little bit
let's let's jump on over to group a ray
Robson versus you and Ludovic hammer
this looks like a pretty interesting
game yeah well Queens are off the board
but the position is just almost all of
the pieces in White's territory which is
very strange to to see it seems like
these Knights are just crawling all over
white in this case let's back up several
moves and see how this how this came to
be
we had somewhat of a Kings Indian
structure without Queens on the board a
game of more positional nature and it
seems like around this point after 92
this is where hammer starts infiltrating
with the pieces starting with Knight f4
after Knight G 393 is played
and this is a very annoying night in in
lights territory now where it is
targeting a lot of a lot of key squares
it is for the time being attacking the
pawn on b2 ray decided to counter-attack
in this position with nine five hitting
the pawn on d6 prompting black to
retreat the bishop to f8 and then I like
to remove that ray played in this
position pawn on e5 not really worrying
about the b2 pawn if the pawn were to be
captured here there would be the simple
rook to d1 and the knight would be
skewered and white would very soon pick
up the b7 pawn so instead of Knight 8b2
hammer played Knight to f6
after f3 Brooksie to further
infiltration and we can see the
combination of rook and Knights are a
bit pesky in this position it's not so
easy for white to remove these pieces
the knight very nicely controls the C 1
square so why can't even really
challenge the the C file going forward
here ready to fend of the pawn with b3
now 9 h5 Knight to c4 and 9h f4 so the
Knights are now according very nicely as
well
and lock is now threatening this pawn on
g2 so I really have to admire the way
hammer is just continually improving the
pieces and in keeping the initiative in
the position ready responded here with
Bishop to d2 obstructing the rook from
attacking g2 after rook to c8 9 fe 3 and
this is where things are getting a bit
confusing
given that look at the rook on c2 the
rook is actually trapped in this
position
I'm realizing maybe hammer went a bit
too far into White's territory maybe
maybe is now regretting it given that
okay all the squares of the row can move
to are controlled by the white pieces he
was forced to sack the exchange in this
position rook eight takes e4 after
Knight takes e4 rey is now up material
but maybe the hammer is going for a
little bit of compensation here after a
90 to check lock is still very very
active King H 2 and now f5 and rook FD
one brings us to the current position
where okay white is up the exchange it's
back to move and hammer now has to prove
some sort of compensation if I can hold
on and perhaps eventually neutralize
after raise us move rook FD 1 he's over
defending the bishop on d2 to
potentially mobilize and I don't see for
now that the knight isn't tied down to
defining the bishop can very easily
imagine move like 93 coming next to try
and remove the rook and also target f5
so it's hammer to move he does have a
time advantage but a material deficits
and not sure what he'll play next maybe
it moved like a 4 to simply prevent 93
and gain more space but I do like raised
chances if he can if he can say out of
time trouble of course what about
Harry's bishop on f8 is worth activating
that right now it's a good question I
mean of course the the Knights and the
rook are quite active but the bishop is
just just such a depressing piece with
most of box pawns on dark squares and if
the bishop wants to activate it's going
to take a long time to do so I'm trying
to imagine here how the bishop could
potentially be useful in the position if
it tries to maneuver to a square like d8
it's still restricted by White's pawn I
mean it couldn't maybe zigzag its way
towards a7 the essentially funny
maneuver maybe this is the most ideal
diagonal for the bishop but it just
takes so long to get there I don't think
this is a realistic plan
anytime soon we have other ideas to try
and push maybe h5 and g4 King h7 Bishop
h6 but that also takes a lot of time and
whenever black plays h5 the pawn on g5
will be undefended so it looks like
hammer it chose to take me for and I
would expect ray to recapture here so we
see f4 was not played which means 93 is
still an idea for white in the position
which if I was right I would be quite
excited about get the 93 and come to f5
or it'd be a very nice night restricting
a very bad Bishop so the curious what
Hammer is planning to do here given that
just seems a bit stuck doesn't seem like
it's that easy for luck to make further
progress ok well let's let's jump over
to Group B and I mentioned that go Busey
an in theory could clinch the section
today one of the games that is very very
important to that statement is L Shaun
more dia body versus Stephens Erick now
ok kibou Zion is far and away the
favorite to win this field at this point
it could be now or could be later but as
far as today goes more of the Abadi sits
at 3 points and if he wins and he's
within a two point shot so they're just
mathematically there so what's going on
in more dia bodies Erick yeah I want to
go back a few moves I mean just taking a
glance at this position I really like
white setup given that there's a
defendant passed pawn on e5 more active
rook on c7 the knight could potentially
come into d4 and even though black has a
bishop era it's a very sad dish a pair
at that given that both bishops are just
not doing much in the position this rook
is very sad on he aids the King on e6 is
one of the most active pieces but it's
also a target and let's just go back a
few moves and see how they got to where
they are
when queens were still on the board rook
takes c4 was played and yeah we can see
that white white has a nice pole here
just due to the palm structure and just
black being very very much restricted
interesting decision here by white to
capture with the a pawn rather than the
rook perhaps I'll Shawn wanted to keep
the pressure on the c5 pond given that
black needs to defend it in this
position and now I'm realizing that
after pond b6 white had a very very nice
someone explosive move in this position
pawn to b4 somewhat I first it might
look like a pawn sacrifice but the whole
idea is to infiltrate with the rook and
this is what happened after sea take
before rook c7 and now the b6 pawn is
very weak the rook is very active and
this rook on c7 is preventing black from
castling which is maybe you move that
black would like to play and the king is
now tied down to defending the Bishop e7
so bauxite came to f7 mr. Bishop take b6
white wins back upon King e6 is played
and now 92 just simply getting the
Knights to a more centralized Square
rook e8 King F 2 we can see Steven there
leaning back had hands over his head
ala Shannon just seems to be the much
more confident player just based on
posture in this situation this is the
first day he's not wearing that hat
that's true yeah yeah he usually has his
trademark Fedora which may be sometimes
a lucky charm but props in this case he
he can see the better without the hats
and we see that ok Knight d4 is on the
horizon this King
I have to move up the board quite soon
I'm curious if black can get away with
playing and move like king d5 right away
it feels very uncomfortable though for
black having the king is the most active
piece and sometimes an end games you
want to activate your King you want to
use it as an active player in the
position but in a case like this
White's pieces are swarming around and
this King could potentially run into
some grave danger just to give one one
funny example line if I move like rook
d7 is played and then King II for whites
and move and checkmate in one move it's
all I had
well I initially thought 93 but then the
upon and ig3 with hangar for but there
there is another check in the position
Oh rookie for rookie floor would be
mates now this line probably isn't the
most high-quality line given that after
it d7 black and actually fork the bishop
in the rook but just goes to illustrate
black kids go too far up with the king
and okay blacks time is ticking al Shawn
I know had kind of a slow start to the
tournament but I know he's been feeling
better he was sick early in the
tournament to sin he woke up every day
with a fever every day and I saw him
yesterday he said he woke up yesterday
was the first day this event that he
woke up without a fever he was feeling
much better so good sign for him and if
he can if he can win this game that will
give him some nice boost going into the
final rounds no doubt about it
hey guys I know it's early but we're
gonna take a very short break here
because I've just been told that we have
the one of the likely I guess the likely
winner of Group A Alexei dray of he is
ready to come in for an interview and
we're gonna configure our seating here
to make room for Alexander Letterman I
understand so in will be we'll see you
back here for the interview in just a
few moments stay tuned here to us chest
champs calm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
when you visit st. Louis you'll probably
want to watch the Cardinals for the
Blues what about after the game heading
back to the hotel would be a major error
instead boogie through the city and
discover the music that gave the Blues
their name at the National Blues Museum
Broadway Oyster Bar or even the
legendary Blueberry Hill so whether you
love the Cardinals the Blues or the
Blues come play with us you guys know I
can't play this right st. Lou is always
exploring a moment comes in chess when
you need to test yourself at a different
level chess 24 premium offers the tools
that you need to reach your maximum
potential from hundreds of interactive
video lessons to becoming part of the
chess 24 community you can analyze with
friends or coach your students live you
get twenty four by seven coverage of
chest news and events access to premium
analysis and commentary and the chance
to interact with grandmasters and other
top players and coaches get it bashed
from the best and even challenge them to
a battle be the best chess player you
can be it's time to level up your game
with just 24 Premium Membership
welcome back everyone to the 2018 fall
of chess classic I'm joined by the
leader of group a Alexey Dre of
congratulations let's say winning a very
quick game I should also mention we have
Alexander Lenderman in the studio in
case there's any language barriers but I
do want to kind of jump straight into it
I know you're a caro-kann specialist is
is this an opening that you're you're
playing you knew you're gonna play a
tree game against efore yes it's my
usually open you but I can play another
sometimes that way if I for example but
CCM opener sometimes ago I played French
but Terry fridge it's looks same a
little bit but not same of course and of
course today was very important game it
is idiots surprise move I mean wait II
five five maybe five years now it's very
critical man but it okay maybe next time
if they still move CD Bishop d3 usually
applied here 96 c3 and Queen c7 move I
stopped Bishop before it's my idea but
it's not mainline it's not my line my
mind I think might have six instead of
princess Sarah Bishop before Bishop g4
Queen b3 Queen discernment a lot of
theoretical a lot of games here maybe
more than one thousand so I prefer twin
sister when I had my way Queen c7 I made
the - yes if Knight of three I complete
Bishop g4 and my position is very good
because the problem is bishop in Catalan
French in Cara if I saw probably this
Bishop and I'm okay
ninety-two and Bishop g4 so or the
bishop before of course I can take on
the four if F 3 F 3 I can take our
template Bishop d7 and pawn on the three
is not good
after Bishop before maybe I can play e5
here so okay every it's not too critical
right late castle this is the best ecigs
and I guess used new idea between the
one I played already with some Chinese
player actually saw that game before but
before the broadcast started you young
and maybe I played Bishop e2
I don't remember because it was right to
play maybe I played I think you're right
but after Bishop is do it slightly
better for forward slightly but into
bishops and of course it's not critical
but I lost the dream
I mean record game against ung and of
course I after the game I need solve
this problem improvement yes yes and I
find very interesting game here
I played 96 years but during the game I
don't know what because it will be
difficult for me remind from what I
start Bishop d6 or 96 just finally I
played 9 f6f-3 witness - Queen h4 and so
now you can not avoid and so what to do
as I remember in some intermediate
komova somewhere I play through J but
it's good for for my bit for rapid game
or bits but not for serious what is the
point of virtually it just I won't I
prepared Bishop d6 I won't take but I
sacrifice podium take on which serum but
I think itís
check which it was not my person but
okay forgot about who jteds was just
this idea and so what to do what to do
I applied you should be six no no I
played Bishop d6 yes and very strange
it's looks twenty positional because
after Bishop g6 FG seeds I have double
pole I have bad pun on acid but it's not
true
it's just looks at the position it's
absolutely normal for me absolutely
normal and and I simply position that
absolutely okay but of course it's
unclear if you play Knight f4 it and
played just didn't have seven and Bishop
d6 who create and hinge eight if
necessary but it's not mastery Kim Cano
semanas good and sometimes ready for a
five and I can say that his business
maybe if f2 92-93 Y position is much
better but when yes but ponen f3 stay
not so good that's why I can play so
strange because it's so strange really
strange for first you it's it's strange
purple amethyst plane but it's not of
course it was preparing how he played a
bishop before yes I remember white
played Bishop before in an advice but I
forgot who to d5 yes yes it's critical I
afraid if tato is instead of major - I
did al bit afraid during the game th one
move Englishman V afraid because I can
play e5 now of course because new just I
just can't and I need to take on b2 he
invite me to a pawn Knight B 292 now I
remember evaluation breakers okay here
may be better but during the game it was
not so clear understand what was the
best move here because
I'm sure black is okay if you if you ask
computer it will be okay for that may be
better but maybe it was good practical
chance for way but okay so it was but I
can't recommend it of course 92 is much
better 92 now if v e5 so I solve my
problem is upon if I've Bishop Bishop
ETS Bishop d6 just finish my development
might be three part f-22 castle and
clean j5 maybe 25 look so it looks it
looks unnatural I'm not a ninja faith
but not maybe not mistake right afraid
if I I think not here I mean if if I
play out 81 for example normal maybe
maybe my 384 something maybe now maybe
after locate have to repeat I don't know
in some reason strictly addition to
ninja 5 it already looks very pleasant
for for black after he 5 no it's enough
to was possible King c7 I saw open the
problem but I can say that I am better
just echo a simply go play a political
for both side mistre 5 looks a little
bit strange I don't know we still don't
compute our opinion about this movement
maybe it's not a mistake but looks
little bit stretch Queen c7 no no yes
you must protect and Paget they met on
GT looks not so good because my pawn GC
it's a stop night it looks like good
anything for me and but magic tree is
normal move defense mode just defense
it's not effective move of course just
the protect pawn on h2 magic ok
I don't know Bishop of tour maybe Bishop
of two not so good but Rojo a e1 was
necessary
you may remember the analyze decide it's
5-minute circles especially maybe
varieties of is normal to here maybe
some problems I forget what we analyzed
after look at one it 8485 is yes that's
why I display yeah it seemed like Bishop
f2 was perhaps the first be first-team
mistake positional position that it's
normal mode but it is wonder if or after
you for well first of all I undressed
minute before I was mostly kind of
letting Indian fish performing for my
queen it wasn't trapped but there I
thought was I was fine so I kind of
underestimated then I thought I have a
clever move Bishop III but as soon as I
let me slow down there cuz I don't think
the oblong audience are following you
after Bishop e3 h6 queen g6 97 is what
you're saying
yeah and the quickest
yes so yes bishop is serious state one
day but I think the queen is quite safe
already
maybe blood position is better yeah I
just seem like that white pieces were or
just in the way of each other like the
Queen but after h6 no chances finish or
maybe Bishop Bishop was the best chance
look local team who maybe was the best
chance g5 and Bishop g5 it's no
sacrifice on the move AG in g5 so about
Luke f7 move it is 94 I don't like
active moves work of 7 this 94 idea
what's technical position of course but
ok what to do white plate Alex played in
Devon it's of course jfif and
just a matter trapping the Queen 97 nice
move because after Bishop h6 Nagi 97
disappear signal g6 in j5f - very nice
sometimes for for this variation because
the shipper [ __ ] chooses so 796
Bishop take g3 Bishop 3 okay and what is
AG I'm ok no maybe it's yes it's also
good it's also good but if - yes we can
bet yes so after my t7 no no chances no
chances
so yeah this is where black just
resigned very quick game I think this is
a quickest game of the tournament
especially with the black pieces I'm
sure it's a nice nice game going into
the final rounds for you I do want to
ask you've written a whole book on the
caro-kann a few years ago do you have
any other books on the way yes about
in-game book and a book and the very
soon it will be publish particle entry
it's very interesting I think it will be
very useful book and the very interest
because my exercises I find it is not
from another form I might have to check
and it's its new positions formerly
appeared from from another tournament
and I think it will be very useful so I
think I stopped right about open you
sure yeah my middle name ever game it's
more interesting you can you come to
read my book if it's opening a book in
in 10 years that's because continually
yes yes but you can leave my book about
middle game when you've for a long time
so so I would
very nice and I know you like you you're
clearly leading leading group a
currently you have two more games to
play any thoughts about the the final
two games you have luck yet - we lose a
game so far so you're just going to take
it one game at a time
okay um it does not finish okay it's not
it's distance I said oh yeah I will let
you go congratulations on your victory
today and best of luck in your crowns
thank you so we're gonna continue
coverage and let's take a look at the
game that is still underway between Ray
Robson and un lugar wood hammer Ray is
up the exchange still when we last left
he was seemed like hammer was in a bit
of a predicament and just going back to
the position where he left off we saw
blacks pieces in the heart of White's
territory but what having it everything
relatively under control after 92 king
h2 this is where we saw f5 and then the
trade on e4 and now we see hammer his
idea of Knight to c5 we're treating the
Knights but putting pressure on the e4
pawn which doesn't seem like great can
defend efore in this position after a 93
was played there is a counter-attack
against the rook on c2 Brook to be 2 and
now Bishop to b4 d4 pawn came off the
board and after rook dv1 the rooks got
traded and seems like Ray is still up
the exchange for a pawn in this case and
after 94 Knight c4 Knight to b5 rook c1
this brings us to the current position
where it seems like Reyes is still the
one playing for a win having the
material manage and having some nice
it's a nice pressure against this d6
pawn currently all of black's pieces are
are kind of defending the pawn so we
will have to keep an eye on this this
game but i do want to welcome back and
simon to the studio that any updates for
us any
that have finished since we last had you
here no we've had no gaems finished
still the two key matchups are the only
ones that are through we try to get a
word with Havana sky boozy and following
his victory he actually that game was
over right before we went to air so he
is not on the chess campus right now but
if he clinches we'll definitely want to
talk to him but yeah not a lot has
changed in the Boros new game where eval
wise Baros is looking like he's going to
end it in a moment but also Ashwin Aram
and Sergei as a Ralph let's take a look
at this game because we haven't really
yet it's in Group B Ashwin is one of
those Ashwin is one of the top players
right now as far as points go so let's
take a look so he has a mathematical
chance of touching goo busey yes I have
everything slight right now either but
slight doing his favor though yes yeah
the the immediate thing that catches my
eye of course is the time situation
Austrian having under 4 minutes left to
make about 11 more moves I want to go
back here because things are a bit
complicated let's see how they got to
this position you can go back even
further
counting material it seems like White's
does have an extra pawn but the
structure is a bit damaged isolated pawn
on III like having some nice activity a
lot of pieces pressuring the Kings side
after this move Queen g6 there is
immediate threat of 9:03 with the Royal
fork against the king and the Queen so
Ashwin played Bishop g3 I think the
strategy for white in a position like
this where you're up material but you're
you're defending is to simply trade
pieces you can get more pieces off the
board then ideally Ashwin look would
like to reach a situation where he's
just a pawn up and ending with perhaps
and winning chances but after h6 king h1
Bishop to e5 seems like Sergey is doing
a nice job of keeping tension in the
position Bishop on e5 very nicely
centralized and if Ashton trades on e5
this would allow the night
to activate and come into the game so
still pressure here that why it has to
do with Bishop f4 was played rook bd8
simply centralizing the rook Queen g3
and now perhaps an unexpected trade
Bishop takes c3 Knight takes c3 and then
at night to b4 looks like black is
trying to sneak into White's territory
perhaps pondering the threat of of night
2 D 3 and now Ashwin's time is ticking
he has fallen below three minutes and
normally if a knight can enter the
territory we see this a lot in many
different middle game scenarios we saw
this in the game between hammer and
Robson as well when a Black Knights
arrives on d3 it can be a very pesky
piece for the white player given that
black will be controlling so many
squares in White's territory looks like
we have a game that is finishing here as
you see arbiter might come or go to one
of the boards wonder which game that is
I'm trying to think back I was in the
playing hall at the beginning of the
round by right which two players were
see that sock shots game och shot with
black against Conrad holt it looks like
action has lost conrad hold with the
victory and that is final in B ouch yeah
tough some tough results for oxygen
especially in the recent rounds Conrad
has sinamay just crushing position here
let's go back and see how this happened
seem like black is was trying to perhaps
sneak through after Queen h6 King G
eights on f4
it's Conrad with the King side attack
after rook a c8 Queen goes back to h3 9h
7 now f5
I'm a bit confused how the game ended
because this shows to be the current
position but black played the final move
it's very weird for black to play the
final move and for the game to end in
White's favor but I can imagine that 9
th 6 is on the horizon I'm wondering if
oxide may have just flagged in this
position maybe tried to play you take
out 5 around at a time
not sure if we can get clarification on
that but the position seems very nice
for white after 9 of 5 the King would
have to move if it moves to h8 there's
my take out of 7 moves to g7 there's I
take fi with check probably have to move
to f8 but then after the simple Brook
take out 5 light is just crashing
through rook DF line on the horizon also
I Simon pawn nearly impossible to defend
so I will never know about that clock
looks like Mike comer has turned it off
well it's good same power that is true
one way of looking at it but props to
Conrad 4 for finishing off the attack in
some nice fashion have to ask him later
if how the game actually ended but maybe
we can switch gears here you did bring
up the Christopher you gain given that
Denis seems to be in a very nice
situation trying to find that game box
King site has opened up dramatically we
can see that ok the king is now on f7
it's funny when we last saw this game
there was a pawn on d4 attacking a
knight on c3 this was over a half-hour
ago and the pawn is still attacking the
Knights let's go back to that moment
when Locke did play pawn before and Eric
while you go back to this moment I do
understand we're gonna have conrad hole
in for an interview
ok so take it away while we get him set
up yeah let's check out to see how the
game between Denis and Christopher is
developing and let's just admire the way
that Denish plays in this position given
that he just puts all the focus on the
Kings side rather than dealing with the
Knights be
attacked on c3 we see pawn h6 was was
played in seemingly brilliant fashion
given given the nature of the pawns here
Bishop f6 was playing the response
Christopher
surprisingly leaving all the tension
giving the option to lights which pawn
to capture there is a number of captures
in this position that Denis could
consider Queen h2 is played leaving the
tension even further seem like tension
is just a theme of this game given the
pond tension on the kingside the tension
on the queenside it's incredible how
both players are just not releasing the
tension but trying to improve their
pieces rook fp8 trying to further
increase attention and after H take g7
Bishop takes g7 now now the dust is sort
of settling but after the King lands on
f7 I would be terrified if I were back
here and the bishop is staring down
against this diagonal combined with
night pressure 86 and then of course
this King side battery seems like White
has a few different options to consider
here between Queen h5 check maybe Queen
take h7 and both players running low on
time but I do like white's chances to
come out on top
given that he's been able to keep the
initiative so we'll keep an eye on this
game but I do want to welcome Conrad
Holt into the studio first time joining
us
congratulations Conrad on a nice victory
thank you so I want to go back this is a
game that we haven't been taking didn't
really take a close look at until the
final moments first of all I want to ask
about the final position because the
last move that we had on the broadcast
was e take f5 he lost on time and buying
this man oh so he did flag okay
but it seemed like you were you were
just crushing anyway 496 coming yeah
take us through the game I know it was a
somewhat of a sharper opening variation
was this something that you were
preparing
for the rounds no no so what what were
you expecting
again stock shots like Moscow variation
uh-huh so yeah I've played an ox shot
many times and I have looked at many of
his games but I don't recall him playing
the specific variation with D takes e4
so were you completely caught off guard
or were you prepared to a certain point
yes ma'am I mean for like the UH as far
as like Queen e2 I think is a theory
okay so going forward I mean I knew the
general ideas of like 93 vision bikini
for myself so just yes pretties I
remember fitting uh-huh yes he was
pretty direct for white to try and go
for this this King side attack
especially with the pawn on e5 now after
rook ad one where do you think
Oxshott went wrong in the game was it
just high management or was there
specific critical moments well as far as
news go I thought after I played 9h - I
thought a night h7 let me get to that
point after h4 yeah you're clearly
continuing with your attack and then
unmoved 25 small midnight eh - yeah yeah
at this point it rose he could play 97
which I hadn't seen before and then um
my attack isn't really going so smoothly
anymore because of 94 he just goes h5
and in the key point is that f6 is
defended so I can't go clean and 6 906
anymore AHA so yeah you could enter with
your queen but it seems like just not
enough defender is on i'm f6 at this
point you you remember how much time he
had left after that h - mm-hmm just not
a lot of time to make 15 more moves so
he played Queen d5 instead and this is
where we see my g4 and did you feel very
confident that you're gonna win around
this point yeah
this seemed like I had a crushing attack
at least um I mean maybe it's all
ejected Lee winning but it's definitely
crushing enough for somebody knows two
minutes left
very nice yeah just from a practical
standpoint with Queen age six always
looming Queenie Ford played and asked
for a very nice move seem like a very
instructive attacking game given kind of
initial structure we see this sort of
structure with a pawn on e5 and many
different types of openings and yeah the
final moves here seemed pretty nice for
whites f5 and it is pretty rare that a
player will flag in a game where there's
thirty-second increments has this
happened to you before either your self
lagging or one of your opponent's five
oh yeah I even like flag and drawing
position that's that's got to be
heartbreaking always have to keep the
clock in your peripheral vision so I do
want to ask because I know you've you've
played in st. Louis before you've played
at least one u.s. championship and
you've to got Championships and I know
some Junior Championships as well
recently you you've begun the job at
Google how is that going so far and how
are you able to balance working at
Google and also playing chess on the
side I mean it's not it's not like um
some super demanding job where they want
you were 60 or here's something I know
sometimes people think it's like that
but I think they're confusing with like
stirrups oh my gosh and I do and and
they're very extremely flexible about
like taking time off and stuff or like
um and also the scheduling going so I
was able to take work half-days remotely
so that I could I need not use too many
vacation days that's nice I know there's
another player in this group Ashwin
Jayram who doesn't have that same
flexibility to work remotely and has to
go to work most mornings before the
rounds do you get a chance to play chess
with other Google employees I know
there's another well-known player
International Master Luke Harmon Vlade
who also works at Google how what's the
chess culture like at the company well I
like you know either like you know put
people on cameras or anything other
people do that but um one thing that you
have is interesting thing they have is
sometimes they have talks about like you
know famous players like they've had a
Kasparov and Hans come to the campus
till I give talks about stuff and there
was about Carlson many cancels well
hopefully they'll get it back here guy
if he's willing to return well
congratulations on your victory again
and best of luck in the final two rounds
thank you and we're gonna take a look at
the game still going on let's go to
let's go back to the Christopher you
game things are heating up they're only
on move 26 both players in severe time
pressure given that okay they still have
14 more moves to make until time control
and whites attack just seems to be
crushing at the rook and the Queen and
the Knights combining against the bishop
on g7 the last move that white played
was rook H to g1 maybe we can go back
after King Teague of seven just want to
see how Dennis just continued this month
just attack knife to f5 taking advantage
of the pin against East six pawn so of
course this pawn is uh is unmovable on
on e6 after B takes c3 finally
Christopher has grabbed the knight which
has been attacked for so many more so
many moves since before was played but
after Queen take age 7 rook to g8 black
is op apiece
it really doesn't feel like it white has
so much initiative and seems like the
whole focus is on the kingside update
the board here because King to Yates was
plain it is now white smooth and I do
want to welcome back and Simon to the
studio welcome back man any updates any
more results sir we have one result in
group a a kobe ins game with Eric Hanson
has been drawn it was down to a bishops
of opposite color situation and there
wasn't much there but there is a nifty
little tactic over in another game
between Ray Robson and you and what
Ludwig hammer
Ray has taken a pawn is sacked upon sack
tonight for a pawn it looks like but
there's some nifty tactics here I'd like
to take a little the current position
there is Forks all over the place
Black is for kima the bishop in the
night also the bishop and the rook with
the nine on b3 let's go back and see how
this happened and try and make some
evaluations here so this is where okay
things look slightly more quieter Knight
d4 is played and we see right here
grabbing the the pawn on e5 this is
actually a discovered attack tactic
simply because the rook is now being
discovered along the open C file and in
fact were to take back five light could
hammer down with her creates pinning the
bishop to the King and there would be no
defense to to rip take a fade in this
position see what you did there
right nice thank you so after Knight
takes e5 hammer decided to play Knight
c5 obstructing the rook keeping the
keeping the attack against a knight also
threatening at night take B 3 and now
Bishop takes c5 was played afternoon I
take b3
looks like hammer is winning back some
material but I mean he's currently down
the full rook so even if he wins back
online or piece he will still be down
the exchange we can imagine that rain
would like to save his rook in this
position imagining some move
perhaps rook to be won and then after
Knight takes e5 the whole sequence of
moves there it seemed like a fancy way
of just trading pieces we were gonna
have the same material situation in this
position where light is up the exchange
for a pawn and I still very much like
raised chances but it's still going to
take some work
we'll take some endgame technique to
actually convert the material advantage
into a win so keep an eye on on this
game if we jump over to Group B I think
we're about to see a handshake between
burrows and you as we've seen that game
progressed to where well made is
calculated who's just being a few moves
away mm-hmm
antennas poros we have not had them yet
in this video hey look very nice when
yesterday against ostrich Andhra maybe
we can get him for an interview after
this game if he dies spring managed to
converts going forward here all the
focus was on g7 and Christopher you
decided it's time to run a king Yates
and there it is trying to find safety
but and now we see the black King has
fallen over that's two wins in row four
tennis Boros I don't see that too often
the that's very cinema dramatic like you
know what the king the lion over there
on the side it's what every child thinks
the chess world is like but then again
you is 11 years old so it's interesting
there's comer with the official
placement congratulations to Danish law
Roche
I can't say that when I resigned in the
chess game I I tipped down my king I
just I just pause the clock shake the
hands and that's I'm not willing it's
you it's not dramatic enough go down so
dramatically exactly okay in other news
in Group B more idea body and zerk this
is another one that kind of stands out
at this moment yeah and things
things are getting tactical that game is
the stage of the game where tactics are
still very relevant especially when it
comes to pass pawns
I'm going to go back
just a few moves see how this pawn
landed so far down the board after a six
was played King D 896 seemed like black
was just under constant pressure now he
7y just threatening to promotes king d
salmon was played rook d5 check
sacrificing the Knights of course if the
King captures and Knights which was
played the pawn can simply promotes in
this position and that's what we see al
Shawn just doing their d8e a queen was
played and after King take d5 we have
somewhat classic material imbalance
white having a queen for rook and Bishop
she excuse me rook Bishop and pawn so
from a point value standpoint it is as
may be balanced material but in many
cases of the queen is just so much
powerful than the rook and the bishop
because especially in a case like this
the rook the bishop and the king are not
so well coordinated especially this
bishop completely out of play on h7 and
now it's white to move all shawn has his
time
- perhaps aver over the number of
different checks he can play to start
attacking the the targets and blacks
position it looks like you can very
easily pick up this g7 pawn
whenever he wants or even the H warp on
that move like Queen D eights could
could be a simple fork given that it
attacks a king upon and the rook just
seems like a very fun position for white
to play yeah for white definitely the
fortunes have definitely turned to the
negative for Stephens er today it looks
like someone just kind of open up the
chest bag and dump the black pieces at
random spots there's there isn't a lot
of coordination there and white has so
many options good for Al Shean though on
the the healthy upswing here today in
st. Louis it's very true so good number
of decisive games it seems like given
that we've already had a couple of
victors in the studio
yeah in groupie three white wins so far
today and it looks like else Jean is
he's looking pretty good here so that'll
be four and then we have a rook and pawn
endgame in the final group B game
between Ashwin and aza Rob did you have
anything you wanted to look at in group
a though they can take a glance at this
game between I'll sure as our of because
it's a type of position it should be a
drop block has some very nagging
advantage not only with an extra pawn
black does have three against two but
also that's the more active rook on b5
now I'm realizing okay after blacks
awesome of King to f7 black also has a
more active King if the King can perhaps
walk its way to before it could
potentially be more more quick than
White's King in entering the the Queen
side territory his light is still very
far away on h1 so I would I would guess
that Azara was gonna play this for a win
we can imagine okay light would like to
get the King back into play after keen
e6 hang up to King d5 keen III it seems
like d4 will be the main entry points
for the black King and this is around
the time we're off shooing we'll really
need to start calculating not to not to
allow the black King to come and just
easily win the pawn on b3 if King d3 has
played King before we might see some end
game like this where black is black
seems to be dominating I'm realizing
there it might be a funny line here if
work to a1 King it takes b3 rook b1
check black King does become a little
bit stuck on the edge of the board would
have to move back to a4 to defend the
rook now after rook a1 check King before
the King could escape via c5
so I would think if the players get to a
position like this and black hats some
nice winning chances but going back to
the current position it is offering to
move and Ashwin might be realizing that
boxing is quite fast in the situation
and maybe considering some other options
another option may be to consider it so
if Ashwin realizes that it's just gonna
be a long slow loss in that King race is
there any way to entice the a and B
pawns off the board both of them that's
a very good point it would be the the
dream situation and if both of these
pawns come off the board should be a
very easy draw for whites I don't know
if I can force this in any way though
anymore the rook could activate this
would allow black to capture and then
light would be very happy yeah
but black could just start marching the
King after King e6 and then the plan
would be to get the King to be six
defend the pawn and put the pressure
back on the b3 pawn so this is another
idea that I'm sure Ashwin is considering
in addition to potentially activating
his King he could try and consider
activating his rook and there might be
some idea of swinging the rook over to
attack the pawns from the Kings side but
then there would be a nice move for a
black pawn g5 and the rook on d5 is very
nicely placed defending both pawns while
frustrating the pawn and b3 and seems
like white rook isn't the most effective
piece in causing black any any sort of
issues seems like black has everything
under control
another game that we haven't looked at
yet today in group a is one that Jen
Shehadeh I think would find the position
to be humorous or delightful settlement
versus bruised own and I say that
because you'll notice that the current
position kind of looks like a heart do
you see that a little bit she likes
those puzzles I'm really trying I don't
see super hearts come on it kinda looks
like a heart up there okay now I know
I'm beginning to see it very imaginative
II creative yeah let me try and draw the
shape oh yeah you can try that can try
and like draw the hearts in this and
this when I teach younger students I was
a little over 7 and d6 but you know this
apologies yeah but something like this
yes and the white pieces like that's if
rip d2 is played then maybe the heart
will be a bit more aesthetic well you
know the last move that the knight just
moved from d2 so it looked through the
last move yeah and then like mm-hmm
okay so white would have had to play
Queen g5 and then King d8 and then then
we would see the hearts just illustrate
this this would have been pretty
magnificent I'm sure if you were he's
got the point so I like it enough
already okay so what's going on in this
game bruise own at three and a half
points in the standings for group a one
of the frontrunners
how do you assess this chaos I mean it
is messy both Kings have Castle
queenside not something you see every
day coming from early on in the game and
speaking of chaos we should immediately
know at the time situation suffer among
having his time ticking below a minute
now below 20 seconds needs to play
quickly for the next two moves they are
mm38 looks like he just played something
there
Oh Queen techie for slope Queens are
getting traded I do have to admire
blacks position though psych Brazilian
is debating what to take back but he
does take with the rook on e4 and it is
equal material but well black structure
and locks piece coordination just seems
to me a lot more pleasant double Brooks
on the open he filed White's pawns are
pretty ugly isolated double pawns on
that file isolated pawn on h3 seems like
it's going to be perhaps a positional
grind down for black now we do see Seth
Roman has left the board he played this
for you if move rook to g1 Andrew zone
playing quickly in response Knight h5
nice multi-purpose move defending the
pawn on g7 and attacking the pawn on f4
and players have now reached move 40
additional half-hour has been added to
both of the clocks I really like blacks
chances in this game seems like just a
technical grind down given that this f4
pawn there's very few ways to defend
this pawn given that no rook can come
behind and defend it because after you
pawn is a bit in the way and meanwhile
black will have ideas of perhaps a
simple or a fades maybe even over
defending maybe a move like rookie 7 to
the FEM the g7 pawn so that the knight
can then capture on f4 usually when I'm
teaching more beginner students I like
but I like them to define what a
weakness is in chess when you think of a
weakness it's usually something that's
easy to attack and hard to defend and I
think the f4 pawn is just a prime
example of a weakness is or it's just so
easy for black to attack and a lot more
difficult for white to defend it's only
defended by the bishop and it seems like
it's gonna be falling at some points in
this game inevitably yes
okay so this is the current position in
this one right this does yeah this is a
current position after the h5 we'll see
this a lot when players make move 40
they usually tend to slow down and start
maybe acclimating to the additional time
that they have so fresh off of his
victory and the dramatic King tipping
game we do have Danish burrows about to
come into the studio but I do have to
mention in Group A there is still one
game we haven't looked at at all as far
as one's being in progress and it's the
game who's above and spirits we should
maybe stop in and see that while we get
or a hooked up certainly yeah let's go
back and see what's going on in this
game seems like a very nice space
advantage for whites given two very nice
Center Khan's let's back up several
moves and see how they've reached this
scenario we could even go back all the
way and check out the opening haven't
seen two too many openings today given
that we do start about two and a half
hours into the round so we'll see that
ok the players nted very trendy opening
these days high level chest just a Slav
formation from lack in this case of semi
Slav which is actually very similar to
an opening that I like to play with the
white pieces the London opening in this
case black setup is very reminiscent of
the London trying to develop the pieces
in the most harmonious fashion after 9 H
for white is going after the bishop hair
right away Bishop to e4 was played f3
and then Bishop g6 so it seems like very
soon the knight will capture on g6 to
win the bishop pair and that's what we
see just going forward here in Knight h
e6 was played H take g6 and rook to c1
and this is around the point where white
was what was perhaps happy to be solid
and of course later on in the game
extended with e4 now for anyone watching
online you can view all
all of the games on us chef champs calm
but we're gonna have to go away from
this game for just a moment because we
do have a special guest in the studio
after a thrilling win over the youngster
Christopher you amazing yeah we were
taking a look at the game when when
things were getting crazy and I do want
to get your thoughts in the game because
there was a spectacular finish just all
of your pieces yeah I mean on the
blocking we had to spend a lot of time
calculating because one mistake and
you're done
this is the Bishop g5 my Dorf [ __ ] which
is interesting because this is the
specific line that Spassky prepared you
see yes boskie prepared against Bishop
No
so Spassky prepared together with Karpov
to play the Bishop g5 nerd-off so the
Bishop g5 neither of originates from
this Spassky Karpov interesting and I'm
sure you you're a lot more familiar with
in history than me do you prefer playing
this more kind of aggressive and
creative style of chess or do you prefer
the more quieter position well sometimes
you have no choice and sometimes you
have to play conservative but you know
it's never too bad to mate of course
that's uh that's very true
when I felt that I was suffering with
the English and Jacobsen totally
outplayed me and I felt that okay it's
time to change and play a bit more
aggressive well clearly worked out in
this game so I know this is a very
theory of mine at what point were you
kind of still in your you're prepared
territory well there's a lot of trans
positions in this type of structure when
he cancelled that's kind of rare usually
black is waiting with Queen c7 Bishop d7
and trying to attack first and then
maybe Castle actually I beat another
young player in this in the very same
line
actually it's Jeffries jump and beat him
and 23 moves in this line pretty proud
of us young players have to watch out
for you yeah you're you now may be
considered a veteran compared to them
yeah guy compared to them Castle castle
is kind of interesting because that's
deciding way too early
where the black ink is going but it's
still messy looking b1 that's a very
classical move in c 7g four five three
well I was thinking to play or not to
play a three but if I don't stop B for
the pawns will start rolling on me and
go be four a five a four
Knight takes e4 ideas are in the air so
that looks very risky I might be even
worse if I don't play a three yeah I
know positions like this sometimes it's
the balance of attacking on your on your
side but also slowing down your
opponent's attack yes I do like a3 it
seems as if he's a pretty good move but
it's not my idea unfortunately
so after h4 I do want to get to this
moment where things were just getting
completely insane after g6 and before
really had to admire your play given
that after before you did not move your
Knights but you just kept the entire
focus on the Kings side how confident
were you in in your attack in this
position I'm I wasn't that sure because
this position is do or die so if Y just
hesitates a little bit then I would
start exchanging on before move around
at my knight I would be dead lost like
92 Queen a5 okay not Queen a5 between 87
and I'm near lost so the problem is that
Knight takes B 3 is in the air e5 maybe
and everything is on my king and even
though I'm attacking the g6
I'm one tempo short just slow yeah so in
fact both of us thought that b4 is in
pretty good move
and in fact he missed aged six here
which is not hard to miss because it's
standard but it's still pretty
spectacular so let's say if he takes on
c3 I take on eight seven can gauge 8f
takes King takes and Queens I promote
the Queen Queen take rook DG one King up
six clean up for us that would be a very
nice pretty nice yeah happy that I guess
he's not going to go for this one right
so but as long as you have a threat like
that you're happy
keep the focus and I think I think he
underestimated my attack here and if you
can take on c3 you're in big trouble
actually he played Bishop f6 I think
that's not the best I was considering F
takes G 6 H takes g7 rook F 795 he takes
bishop takes d5 b takes b3 a - King
takes a2 a4 b4 Bishop f6 rook takes h7
Wow
so Bishop takes g7 is the only move in
my calculations just to show for the
viewers yes the rook on each side that
can't really be taken because Ricketts
ones yes and then keen takes you seven
check check can the Queen thanks g6 aha
or even Queen h7p a stone is even nice
and maybe - yeah so rotated 7 pretty
spectacular move but Luke takes h7 and
the line continues Bishop g7 and here I
was calculating route h8 King takes h8
Bishop takes f7 now it it looks a bit
drafty on my Kings side but it's pretty
drafty for him - so I thought he has to
play Bishop FA cos rook h1 is
very strong and if the bishop moves to
e5 Queen h6 mate she played he would
have had to play Bishop f8 so I was
considering Queen g5 setting up Queen
takes g6 made after rook h1 so he has to
play d5 b takes wait yeah B takes e5
Queen a six look h1 check King g7 Queen
e5 and Queen f6 losses to row cage seven
check and I'll take the Queen
but if King takes f7 I'm check mate with
the Queen and rook with rook eight seven
just to show that out - this would be
moved
36 yep from a line that would have
deviated from the game I moved 20 yeah
so when you were playing the game did
you see this line I thought all the way
through wow so that's 16 moves ahead
I mean I had to otherwise I'm worse yeah
I I'm just yanking a note of that
because sometimes it's mind boggling for
the the mere mortals who are watching
online - so imagine thinking I had 16
moves in these crazy variation yes and I
mean we spend a lot of time I spend a
lot of time thinking about this so this
is not easy calculation so we were both
going down to 20 minutes than 10 minutes
and down to 2 or 1 minute
so here it went Bishop f6 and like I'm
very close to winning but one mistake
and he's back in the game
so I played Queen h2 renewing the threat
of Queen takes h7 mate and of upcoming
future because let's say if I would have
taken on g7 first Bishop g7 g takes h7
King h8 and if I don't made some how
quickly I might even be in trouble so
Queen age - I think was accurate
Brook FB 8h takes bishop takes G takes f
king takes round here it just seems so
much so fun for whites yeah I mean now
it's great but so you're shaking in your
boots because if you just blunder your
pieces on the queenside you're losing so
but it thankfully everything comes on
tax so queen takes 8 7 8 G 1 and that
rubgy 7 is just a huge threat and Lex
main problem is that the queen is way
too far away and if that Queen would
join somewhere on that fade maybe
there's some hope but it's just too far
yeah so I mean you have to play King g8
well there's many good moves but I felt
that rook d6 is the cleanest
queen bee 897 King f8 room d7 and after
97 I have 96 Andrew g8 mates so it was
pretty adventurous game but certainly
thrilling for for myself and for
everyone watching online this is two
wins in a row for you yeah I know maybe
either slow start to the tournament do
you believe in momentum in the sense
that if you start winning games does it
give you more confidence more energy I
think there's like yeah there's room for
momentum because you know if you learn
and you get in the rhythm of winning
it's much easier to win when you're
drawing like five games in a row
I guess even for him I guess it was
difficult to play a very aggressive game
when he's been very solid and not really
being attacked that much makes sense so
and you know who you play it tomorrow
you think I'm playing zerk uh-huh any
thoughts on that game I don't know yet
we'll see okay well congratulations on
the thrilling win today let you go and
rest and prepare and best of luck in the
final two rounds so we will go back to
the coverage of games which are still
underway we see the Stephen Zerg game is
still
still being played out the queen versus
rook and Bishop material balance is
still present in the position seems like
that seems like Black has lost a few
pounds on the Kings side but black would
really like to focus on the Queen side
but with with advancing the Queen side
pawns last move that was playing his
rook to c6 and now it seems like whites
Queen is a bit out of play there's no
immediate checks against the backing and
there is a threat of rook to c2 which if
if I can win the b2 pawn and have to
connected passed pawns ready to just
storm down the board and maybe there's
some hope for Stephen to survive in this
position certainly a game we should keep
our eyes on I do want to welcome back
and Simon into the studio yet again any
news any updates for us pens yes over in
Group A we have a result ray wraps and
has won his game as white against hammer
as we figured that would be the case but
other than that there are still several
games going on as we near the end of our
show I mean we could take a look just to
see how this Robson hammer game finished
off we saw ray was up to exchange seemed
like just a matter of technique and he
was able to finish off his opponent
pretty quick fashion a bit confused
about this move King h1 seems quite odd
given that okay usually in the endgame
you want to activate your King and not
not pacify your king so King h1 I am
very confused about maybe he's just
getting off a dark square given that
black does have a dark for a bishop
perhaps are some ideas where he would
like to not to be checked along this
diagonal but going forward here at King
g7 g4 just fixing the King side pawns
King f8 now that rook enters b6 now we
see very glaring weakness on d6 now I'm
realizing that maybe Ray's idea with
King H
one was the fact that if the King were
stolen each to going back to this
position if he plays rookie six
immediately now I'm realizing hammer
would have this resource Bishop to d8
attacking the rook and if the rook takes
on d6 there'd be Bishop to c7 so
sometimes whenever you you see a
high-level player at play a very
suspicious or strange move you have to
delve into some of these tactical lines
we see in the game that when the king is
on h1 hammer did not have the same
resource with with Bishop d8 followed by
Bishop c7 now he still played the ship
c8 and Bishop c7 but after rook to f6
check hammer threw in the towel given
that white is now off a clean exchange
and this d6 pawn ready to advance down
the board so very nice win by Rey Robson
who had a pretty devastating loss
yesterday against Bruges owned the game
went over 5 and 1/2 hours where he was
pushing for a win and over pushing and
losing so with a win today Reyes is
still holding his own and so with two
more grounds to to go he can finish
strong and in the meantime in Group B we
do know that the event will not be
decided today probably be tomorrow but
that's gonna do it for today guys but
before we go I'd like to talk about some
upcoming special programming that the
st. Louis chess club will be presenting
you know the Fall Classic is just one of
four seasonal big events these
invitation-only where we invite these
2,500 2,600 level players to st. Louis
some are competing for norms others is
just here to shut the opposition down
and take home the prize money but coming
up after this we're not gonna make you
wait long for the Winter Classic because
it's just next month same format as this
event starting November 5 at us chess
champs calm and you can check out the
roster as it becomes available at us
champs calm as well after that we have
the 2018 st. Louis Invitational it's 210
play around Robins but this is all about
the norms the building blocks to the
titles of chess we have a grandmaster
norm section an international master
norm section and we'll see who the
superstars of tomorrow are when they
emerge from this Invitational event
starting November 16th at u.s. chess
champs calm and then on the world stage
it is the World Chess Championship 2018
you know it Magnus Carlsen versus
Fabiano Carolina are playing in London
in a 12 game match starting November 9
and each day we will have abbreviated
coverage and commentary by yasser Jen
and Maurice it's today in chess and they
won't be covering just the World Chess
Championship they will be covering the
world women's chess championship as well
big news there it's a 64 player knockout
as the champion Jew when June heads in
to that big event trying to retain her
title who will emerge you know Sabina
Pfizer and Irina crush are playing under
the USA flag all right and then finally
we close out the year with the
long-awaited
finale to the grand chest tour in London
once again it's gonna be one heck of a
month in London I'll tell you what the
four top players of the grand chest or
Fabiano Cara wanna hit Cara Nakamura
Levon Aronian
and mvl they'll be playing in a knockout
it's gonna be classical it'll be rapid
and it will be blitz and the winner is
gonna be the ultimate undisputed
champion of the grand chest tour and
this is something that I really like you
know in the past the grand chest tour
has been just all the accumulation of
points to the very end and the winner of
London could very well be not the same
person who wins the grand chest tour but
we're putting an exclamation point
period right on the end of the sentence
and the winner of that event will be the
winner of the tour that's what we want
to see we will see blood and drama until
the final playoff indeed well as far as
this event goes we just have two rounds
left this broadcast was produced by the
world's greatest production B team Tammy
Hyde is the streamer we want to give a
shout out to Eric Mosel today for his
help
Isaac Krantz is on graphics and audio
and Danny Machuca is your technical
director and until tomorrow remember
last day we're gonna be here earlier but
tomorrow we're here normal at the normal
time of 3:30 p.m. at Central and the
games begin at 1:00 p.m. central you can
check them out on us chess champs calm
for international master Eric Rosen my
name is Ben Simon we say so long from
the Show Me State
[Music]
you